27 year old jorge lopez from puerto rico
and a former second round pick by the
brewers back in 2011. he's had four
starts so far with the orioles he has
been very good 2-0 with a 3.8 era
got him with a breaking ball and the
first
hitter of the game goes down on strikes
a little back door action breaking ball
from jorge lopez
and he got him looking so two strikeouts
in the inning for jorge lopez two on two
down
bounce to second alberto backhands flips
to second for the force and the rays are
retired in the first charlie morton
getting his first look at the orioles
here in 2020 his eighth overall start of
the season the record one and two the
era just over five a strikeout an inning
to right field could fall and it's in
for a base hit
around third iglesias they'll hold them
up there and the orioles have the bases
loaded mount castle with a base hit
second hit of the inning for the birds
there it is just right in front of the
right fielder brett phillips phillips
quickly gets the ball in of course jose
iglesias has to hold up
and he did he go yes he did
tripp gibson down at first says severino
did not check
big strikeout for charlie morton his
first of the night out number two two
down and now chancisko tried to deliver
some runs for the birds iglesias on it
third steward at second mount castle at
first
o2 pitch
hit him there's a run
a run the hard way
as chance cisco takes one for the club
iglesias scores and the orioles go on
top one nothing
ground ball third the pickup brassos
throw to first in time to retire the
side they score one lead three one
nothing baltimore
popped up left side brosso
closing in toward the dugout with a play
making the catch to gone and mike braso
a nice job of getting over there and
feel for that railing make the catch
ooh
ouch
oh boy well iglesias just cannot catch a
break this year on anything
oh he's in so much pain
that looked like it got him right in the
forearm top part of the forearm and it
was as solid we could hear the thump all
the way from up here
just that two seam fastball throwing so
hard oh it's off the hand too the left
hand and it was no hesitation once he
got to his feet straight off of the
field
top of the order for the raise yoshi
tattoo good
oh boy and this one is shot deep to
right and that one is gone home run to
right
for setsugo that's number eight and the
razor on the board
a 3-2 pitch and he turned on that one
saw a lot of pitches got a fastball he
could handle and dropped it right on the
other side of the wall to tie this baby
up
down to the fourth joey wendell
this one shot into right on the move
that's going to be over the head of
stewart bounding off the wall
afterburners kicking in for wendell he's
headed for three and he's in there head
first with a triple
joey wendell's third triple of the year
this one leads off the fourth
bounce to second alberto come to the
plate the tag and he is out
two down that wasn't real close alberto
playing in throws a strike to the plate
cisco applies the tag and wendell cut
down ball and two strikes to brett
phillips
got him
so back-to-back strikeouts and after a
lead-off
triple
ray's retired
well two outs with satsugo at first
rosarina d.h tonight
he shoots this one into right that's
well hit and we'll get out of here to
the opposite field
a rosarina takes that 2-2 pitch and
drives it to right field
and out of here
over the scoreboard and the raves take
a 3-1 lead
well the one silver lining
to no fans in the stands as you can hear
dugouts erupt and that's what they did
there the fastball up and away
that's a big one for the rays
his fifth home run of the year
[Applause]
number one in the fifth pulled off of it
that was a a curveball right there that
charlie hung in the middle of the plate
he's happy with the result not the pitch
and he got him fastball away
and mount castle is out on strikes
one two
and the good curveball got him swinging
to retire the side so he goes five
innings and has five hits one run struck
out six all in all a pretty good outing
ryan thompson enters the game with one
out nobody on in the bottom of the ninth
and the pitch ground ball up the middle
backhanded wow's
and that's a nice play indeed
by brandon lau to go up the middle the
backhand
to retire hayes
[Applause]
how about that other side of the bag he
just throws it while he's on a rush did
you see the look by nate lowe i like it
like whoa
that was sweet
and that fly ball short left should do
it
margaux is there and the rays win it one
two three go the orioles in the ninth
the rays win this one
it's a three to one final